everything that happens before death
is what counts
half the fun of the trip is the
aesthetic of lostness
learning to let go should be learned
from learning to get
you don't have to burn books to destroy
a culture
just get people to stop reading them
what's the point of having a library
full of books you've already read
souls can't be sold
they can only be lost and never found
again
if you hide your ignorance
no one will hit you and you'll never
learn
stuff your eyes with wonder
live as if you'd drop dead in ten
seconds
see the world
it's more fantastic than any dream made
or paid for in factories
insanity is relative
it depends on who has who locked in what
cage
the books are to remind us
what asses and fools we are
there's no use going to school unless
your final destination is the library
everyone must leave something behind
when he dies
there is more than one way to burn a
book
and the world is full of people running
around with lit matches
we need not to be let alone
we need to be really bothered once in a
while
how long has it been since you were
really bothered
about something important
about something real
if we listen to our intellect we'd never
have a love affair
we'd never have a friendship
we'd never go into business because we'd
be cynical
don't ask for guarantees
and don't look to be saved in any one
thing person machine or library
do your own bit of saving
and if you drown
at least die knowing you are heading for
sure
life should be touched not strangled
you've got to relax
let it happen at times
and at others move forward with it
you shouldn't talk about things
you should talk about the meaning of
things
the good writers touch life often
the mediocre ones run a quick hand over
her
the bad ones rape her
and leave her for the flies
don't think
thinking is the enemy of creativity
it's self-conscious and anything
self-conscious is lousy
you can't try to do things
you simply
must
do things
first you jump off the cliff and build
your wings on the way down
your intuition
knows what to write
so get out of the way
a book is a loaded gun in the house next
door
who knows who might be the target of the
well-read man
a good night of sleep
or a ten-minute ball
or a pint of chocolate ice cream or all
three together
is good medicine
these do have a smell you know
and if they don't they should
for their feet are dusted with spices
from a million flowers
the word is love
you have to get up in the morning and
write something you love
something to live for
anything you dream is fiction and
anything you accomplish is science
the whole history of mankind is nothing
but science fiction
see the world
it's more fantastic than any dream made
or paid for in factories
ask for no guarantees
ask for no security
without libraries
what do we have
we have no past and no future
we cannot tell the precise moment when
friendship is formed
as in filling a vessel drop by drop
there is at last a drop which makes it
run over
so in a series of kindnesses
there is at least one which makes the
heart run over
you have to know how to accept rejection
and reject acceptance
that's the good part of dying
when you've nothing to lose
you run any risk you want
when they give you lined paper
write the other way
so few want to be rebels anymore
and out of those few
most
like myself
scare easily
the minute you get a religion you stop
thinking
believe in one thing too much and you
have no room for new ideas
the first thing you learn in life
is you're a fool
the last thing you learn in life
is you're the same fool
self-consciousness is the enemy of all
art
be it acting writing painting
or living itself
which is the greatest art of all
death doesn't exist
it never did
it never will
but we've drawn so many pictures of it
for so many years
trying to pin it down comprehend it
we've got to think of it as an entity
strangely alive and greedy
science is no more than an investigation
of a miracle we can never explain
and art is an interpretation of that
miracle
that's the great secret of creativity
you treat ideas like cats
you make them follow you
no person ever died
that had a family
we're just petty insects all of us
fighting on a pinhead planet
if you feel bad alone
it means that you are unlikely to feel
good next to another
it's not books you need
it's some of the things that once were
in books
when a man
is 17
he knows everything
if he is 27 and still knows everything
then he is still seventeen
if a man cries in front of you
it means
that he trusts you
for the first thing a writer should be
excited
he should be a thing of fevers and
enthusiasms
the word politics eventually became a
synonym for communism
i guess you hate people when they make
you feel naked
i mean
by exposing your flaws in the open
that's friendship
each playing the potter to see what
shapes we can make of the other
you